aux etats unis la cia à la recherche
d'un pilote soudanais liés à al qaïda il
aurait l'intention de détourner un avion
sur la maison blanche
information du washington times non
confirmées par la cia mais qui nous
rappelle que depuis plus d'un an un
français zacarias moussaoui est
emprisonné en virginie accusé de complot
il est le seul inculpé à ce jour pour sa
participation aux attentats du 11
septembre
son frère vient de publier un livre nous
serons en direct avec lui dans un
instant mais auparavant retour sur le
parcours de zacarias moussaoui
avec magali sert le 14 août 2001 les
responsables de cette école de pilotage
du minnesota alerte le fbi haye l'un de
leurs élèves
zacarias moussaoui un comportement
étrange les autorités interpelle ce
français de 33 ans qui devant les
enquêteurs tentent de dissimuler son
identité
finalement zacarias moussaoui est
emprisonné il est en situation
irrégulière sur le territoire américain
le 11 septembre
quatre avions de ligne sont détournés et
s'écrase sur le world trade center le
pentagone et en pennsylvanie le monde
apprend avec stupéfaction que les 19
pirates de l'air avaient suivi des cours
de pilotage aux états unis tout comme
zacarias moussaoui pour le viol d'un
jeune français le 20e pirate de l'air
il est inculpé de complicité de complot
terroriste
il y a six charges retenues contre lui
une soeur dont quatre passés de la peine
de mort principal élément à charge
détenu par la justice américaine contre
zacarias moussaoui
ces quatorze mille dollars qu'il aurait
reçu aux états unis de ramzi binalshibh
un homme arrêté il ya quelques jours au
pakistan
il faisait partie de la cellule
d'hambourg par laquelle a transité
mohammed atta ramzi binalshibh avait
aussi lire et de grosses sommes d'argent
à un autre pirate de l'air peu avant les
attentats du 11 septembre le passé de
zacarias moussaoui pèsera aussi devant
les jurés il a séjourné dans des camps
d'entraînement en afghanistan et au
pakistan
le parcours classique des membres d'al
qaïda pourtant au départ tout séparait
zacarias moussaoui de ce monde non
pratiquants il aurait embrassé
l'extrémisme islamiste en angleterre où
il côtoyait les mosquée de finsbury et
baker street
connus pour leurs discours militant
aujourd'hui du fond de sa prison en
virginie
zacarias moussaoui se revendique
esclaves dallas son procès doit débuter
en janvier
il risque la peine de mort